[Musique]
la caisse va continuer sa sortie de la
production de pétrole qu'on a commencé
déjà il y a quelques années pour la
compléter d'ici la fin de l'année
prochaine la fin de 2022
c'est presque ça qui s'est passé la
Caisse de dépôt a pratiquement complété
sa sortie du pétrole en 2017 la caisse
détenait pour 8 milliards 500 millions
de dollars d'actifs dans le secteur
pétrolier fin 2022 il ne restait plus
qu'un seul placement d'une valeur de 200
millions la caisse n'a plus d'actifs
dans l'extraction de charbon elle
maintient ses actifs en gaz naturel
considérant cette énergie fossile comme
étant une énergie de transition et elle
est notamment l'actionnaire majoritaire
faut dire d'énergie charliemont le PDG
de la Caisse de dépôt est avec nous
bonsoir Monsieur il reste un placement
dans le pétrole un seul comme vous avez
dit c'est qui c'est où je peux vous dire
société de nature qui est pas sur les
marchés publics donc c'est pas
simplement une question qu'on contrôle à
100% là qu'on peut dire quand on
considère que c'est le bon moment on
vend parce que c'est sur les marchés
publics c'est une société qui détenue de
façon privée un actionnaire majoritaire
il y a nous on est en discussion depuis
un bout de temps ça fera un petit peu
plus de temps mais essentiellement c'est
la seule chose pour nous c'est complé
parce qu'on est déjà en discussion avec
l'autre propriété pourriez-vous
totalement compléter même si on perd de
l'argent dans ça ben il faut toujours
justement être prudent avec l'argent des
fiduciaires faut pas non plus des
déposants faut pas non plus se mettre je
dirais une pression indus qui fera en
sorte la consommation délicate pour nous
on va le faire correctement mais sans
seulement on est passé de 8 9 milliards
presque plus rien on parle de 200
millions d'après moi ça va être quelque
chose qui va se régler est-ce que c'est
une décision qui coûte cher à la Caisse
de dépôt je regardais l'indice morning
start global énergie de 2022 si je me
trompe pas 20% de rendement positif
l'Impérial oeil la
cac47%, son corps
36%, est-ce que de sortir du pétrole
c'est peut-être la bonne décision
environnementale mais ça coûte du
rendement à la caisse donc pour nous on
le voit pas comme ça coûte du rendement
parce que si on le regarde c'est vrai
que 2022 elle est totalement raison sur
les marchés boursiers fromage seul
secteur qui était en haut cette année
mais nous il y a également qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec l'argent où on le met
ailleurs sur cinq ans si on prend par
exemple exemple le renouvelable parce
que c'est là qu'on est allé déplacer
notre argent donc on vendait sur les
marchés boursiers dans ce secteur
pétrolier on réinvestit dans le
renouvelable même avec la grosse année
2022 secteur pétrolier la production
pétrolière c'était à 7 % par année
pendant 5 ans le renouvelable 20 %. donc
il est possible pour également vendu
cette année vous savez on fait des
profits quand on vend avant ça c'est
juste sur papier donc on a vendu en 2022
maman où les prix étaient très élevé
donc de ce côté-là pour nous on
rencontre notre devoirs de filière quand
on regarde l'intensité
l'intensité carbone donc par dollar
investi la charge en carbone l'intensité
réduction de 53% du
portefeuille par rapport à 2017 53% avec
l'objectif d'aller jusqu'à 60% donc on
approche justement de cette cible là on
est en avance même un peu sur notre
horaire mais comme on dit tout le temps
les choses sont peut-être pas linéaires
mais ça avance très bien et donc vous
allez outrepasser de 60% mais c'est ce
qu'on vise d'ici 2030 puis comme on a
toujours on aime ça être en mesure de
continuer toujours à progresser puis
évidemment faut comprendre le
portefeuille de la caisse avec
l'évolution que vous donnez là
aujourd'hui c'est 80% de d'actifs sur le
400 milliards les actifs à 0 ou faible
émission alors évidemment de plus en
plus difficile à chacun en réduction
absolue toutefois la baisse est moins
rapide on est passé de 21 mégatonnes de
CO2 en 2017 à 14 15 en 2000 en 2022 donc
de façon absolue votre empreinte carbone
demeure encore élevé ben elle est plus
faible que bien nos pères mais c'est un
point très important que vous amenez
l'intensité carbone par million de
dollars ou la cible absolue la baisse si
tu baisses en intensité carbone de façon
par million de dollars investis tu vas
baisser éventuellement de façon absolue
mais il faut comprendre qu'un
investisseur comme on est très différent
d'une entreprise une entreprise elle a
une usine elle doit arriver à une cible
absolue de zéro disons 2050 pour être
carbonne neutre mais nous on n'est pas
une entreprise on est dans 5000
entreprises ça s'additionne ça se
multiplie si on le regarde sur une base
absolue on cesserait d'investir dans les
secteurs qui ont besoin de la transition
parce que nous on multiplie à
l'investissement dans l'entreprise A B C
D donc ça se multiplie alors pour ça
qu'un investisseur ou comme une banque
en général il y a un élément d'intensité
carbone par millions de dollars investis
c'est une meilleure mesure plus
représentative ce qu'on veut c'est
continuer investir dans ces secteur là
mais qui chacun individuellement chaque
entreprise aimer - vous investissez
notamment dans la Banque Royale vous
êtes un actionnaire de la banque royale
la caisse ne pratiquement plus d'intérêt
directement dans la production et le
raffinage de pétrole mais rBC a augmenté
ses investissements d'hydrocarbures de
45% en 2022 vous investissez donc dans
RBC qui investit beaucoup dans les
hydrocarbures et la ça voter contre une
proposition d'actionnaire qui aurait
contraint la RDC a publié ses cibles
absolues de réduction de GS aurait été
beaucoup plus transparente est-ce que
pas un double discours de la part de la
casse ici c'est un élément important que
vous soulevez premièrement faut voir
qu'il y avait à peu près 5 6
propositions résolution 3 4 sur le
climat on a tous voté en faveur de ces
résolutions là sauf celle-ci pourquoi
justement pour le même principe que j'ai
amené le service financier un
investisseur ou un prêteur multiplié sur
une foule d'entreprise et donc pour nous
c'est pas qu'on est contre qui a des
efforts de la part de la banquière
évidemment on a le même discours avec
tout le monde mais pour des secteurs
financiers qui prêtent de façon
multiplier des multiples entreprises
l'intensité carbone
mesurée par millions de dollars qui sont
prêtés ou consentis ou investi est une
bien bien meilleure plus représentative
du de travail qui est fait par une
banque ou un investisseur et donc dans
ce sens à votre avis mais certains de
notre côté s'il y a plein d'autres
résolutions qu'on a voté en faveur on
veut continuer à pousser l'institution à
avoir des cibles faire une réduction de
compte tout ça que oui on prend notre
par exemple une résolution du climat ne
voter en faveur parce qu'on vous laisse
cesser le financement par la Banque
Royale de nouveau projet de nouveaux
gisement donc oui il y a une conséquence
dans tout ça mais du point de vue d'un
secteur financier c'est pas comme une
entreprise de traditionnelle la mesure
d'intensité par millions de dollars
investis et préférable sinon ce qui va
arriver la Banque Royale une autre
institution financière en Seb absolu ça
serait complètement investir dans
certains secteurs ces entreprises là
certaines sont plus polluantes elles ont
besoin de réduire leurs émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et donc de cesser de
les financer ce serait pas avantageux
pour eux pourrai pas faire leur
transriez-vous évaluer aussi la
possibilité de sortir vous sortez du
secteur du pétrole mais pourriez-vous
sortir d'entreprises financière comme la
RBC continue de financer massivement le
pétrole écoutez il y a toujours une
possibilité le vote vous savez c'est un
outil ce qu'on préconise puisqu'on a
beaucoup de succès avec plusieurs
institutions financières je dirais que
chacune à leur façon d'évoluer il y en a
qui sont plus en avance que d'autres la
question climatique sur la stratégie
c'est d'avoir un dialogue avec eux ce
qui est important également on peut
avoir des fois des résolutions qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement précises ici il
y avait non seulement le pétrole on
parlait de Seb absolu pour le pétrole au
niveau électrique et ça l'électricité
c'était plus délicat donc des fois faut
être très méticuleux sur comment la
résolution est écrite parce que parfois
il peut avoir certaines incohérences
c'est ce qu'on veut c'est inscrit dans
un dialogue est-ce qu'elle continue à
s'améliorer à chaque année parce que
sinon le vote toujours l'arme ultime et
là on arrive dans un des fois un Bridy
dialogue c'est ce qu'on cherche à faire
différemment merci merci Charles merci
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI